bonsoir On vient d'entendre Gabriel qui
a fait une déclaration d'amour au Sénat
au début de son discours mais il ne vous
a pas répondu lors de sa brève réponse
de 7ette 8 minutes ça vous déçoit
écoutez déjà il a fait une déclaration
d'amour au Sénat et surtout à la droite
sénatoriale dont il a besoin pour faire
passer ses réformes injustes souvent
conservatrice pour pas dire
réactionnaire donc il y a pas de
surprise en la matière mais pour cet
homme qui se dit jeune moderne ue
d'institution le fait qu'il réponde dans
sa déclaration finale à tous les groupes
de droite et pas un mot il un petit mot
pour Marie scarer que oui mais bon voilà
un petit mot mais Marie scarer fait pas
partie entre guillemets du pôle des
trois groupes de gauche ça serait donc
je je le regrette je dire c'est pas
c'est pas très
correct voilà c'est un petit signe c'est
vrai que nous avons été les plus
critiques de sa politique mais il aurait
pu dire tout simplement bah écoutez vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec ma politique
mais je vous respecte il aurait pu au
moins dire ça je suis déçu déçu
d'ailleurs aussi sur le fond du discours
parce que finalementou comment vous
qualifiez ce discours
macroniste d'abord tout d'abord c'est un
discours de répétition puisque hier nous
avons eu à peu près le même discours et
même au mot près dans beaucoup de de
circonstances donc venir au Sénat pour
répéter ce que nous avons entendu hier
de manière très plate de Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire j'aurais vraiment espéré qu'il
y aait beaucoup plus de choses sur les
collectivités territoriales sur la
vision de la décentralisation
rien ou quasiment rien non c'est
décevant c'est décevant pour les
sénateurs donc pour la chambre des
collectivités territoriales oui vous
avez été déçu il n'y avait pas assez sur
ce sujet des collectivités il a été
question de des préfets de la vision
pluriannuelle des préfet de plus de
sévérité à l'égard des agresseurs d'élus
locaux il a parlé de déconcentration il
a parlé du poids de l'État
essentiellement dans les territoire mais
pas de la place des élus donc un
discours pour moi très faible sur cette
dimension que nous attendions au Sénat
vous estimez qu'il a réellement viré à
droite euh Bruno rotillot ne l'entendit
pas de cette oreille tout à l'heure non
non non il a pas viré à droite il est de
droite je dire il y a pas de virage
c'est la continuité de cette politique
depuis des années moi j'ai évoqué le
printemps social libéral de 2017
d'Emmanuel Macron et puis après voilà
tout a montré que ce soit la loi
retraite ou la loi immigration on voit
bien non pas ce virage de droite c'est
la confirmation de l'ancrage à droite de
la majorité présidentielle qui cherche à
élargir sa majorité avec la droite quoi
de plus normal et moi je j'invite
vraiment les gens de gauche sincèr qui
pensent encore que la macronie voà c'est
un entre deux non c'est plus ni un entre
deux ni un en même temps c'est à droite
et à droite votre regard sur l'aide
médicale d'État qui est l'une des
sources pour le coup et bien de
désaccord entre LR et le gouvernement
elle sera réformée mais ça sera par voie
réglementaire et en s'appuyant sur et
bien le rapport evvin stéphanini claud
evvin ancien ministre socialiste écoutez
dans cette maison s'est déroulé à
l'époque de Louis XI la fameuse journée
des dupes et bien oui LR est aujourd'hui
complètement le DUP de cette affaire ils
ont négocié ils espéraent un soutien du
gouvernement sur leur position
concernant la me une grande loi qui
aurait marqué les esprits ça va passer
par voie réglementaire voilà souvent je
m'interroge qui est la marionnette qui
est le marionnettiste on sait depuis pas
mal maintenant de jours que le
marionnettiste c'est Emmanuel Macron et
les marionnettes les idiots utiles ce
sont nos collègues de LR qui continue
comme ça je ne sais pas si ça va durer
moi j'espérais un discours très dur de
Monsieur rotillot pour dire son
opposition par rapport à
rachidti par rapport à la loi
immigration en fait on a vu plutôt un
toutou et je pense que les vrai discours
d'opposition sont venus de la gauche
vous parlez de Rachid hadti un mot sur
la loi p LM Paris Lyon Marseille pour le
coup c'est un sujet sur lequel on a eu
un petit peu plus de détails aujourd'hui
par rapport à hier Gabriel hatal qui
annonce une loi d'ici la fin de l'année
bien pour réformer le mode de scrutin de
ces villes he qui n'est pas qui ne sont
pas des villes comme les autres pour les
élections municipales est-ce que c'est
légitime de et bien revoir ce mode
d'élection je lui souhaite bien du
plaisir quand il expliquera aux
Parisiens aux Marseillais aux Lyonnais
que leurs arrondissements vont
disparaître parce estce que c'est bien
ça dont il s'agit c'est la disparition
des arrondissements et donc de la
démocratie de proximité représenté par
les maires d'arrondissement qu' soitent
de droite ou de gauche parce que
l'élection classique qui existe en
France du maire à partir du conseil
municipal élu par les citoyens ce n'est
pas celle effectivement de ces trois
villes ces trois villes ont un statut
particulier et qui fonctionne bien la
démocratie de proximité au travers des
arrondissements c'est une chose
intéressante et on pourrait même
peut-être plutôt le le développer sur
d'autres grandes villes françaises
d'autres grandes métropole donc ils ont
tout faux ENIT qu' a derrière qu'il a
derrière c'est on a acheté madame Rachid
Dati au travers de Madame rachti on
achète monsieur Sarkozi et pourquoi pas
Monsieur B Boré voilà tout ceci voilà
c'est c'est copains
et l'élection de rachidti candidate à la
paragine pas un seul instant que la
question de Paris n'est pas été dans la
négociation dans la venue de madame
Rachida Datti qui d'ailleurs l'a dit
elle-même au moins elle les cache elle
dit la vérité monsieur Macron se se lui
se cache en disant je n'ai pas parlé de
Paris quand j'ai demandé à Madame Dati
de rentrer et d'ailleurs sans prévenir
son premier ministre ça vous montre où
est le vrai pouvoir le pouvoir n'est pas
à Matignon il est au château bien merci
merci beaucoup Patrick Kenner pour cette
interview cette réaction à ce discours
de politique générale qui a eu lieu au
Sénat lors duquel et ben
Gabriel